the the left's narrative is that white
people are bad and black people are good
and all black people are good and all
white people are bad and
the greatest scourge the most pervasive
evil in the country is white supremacy
and so the george floyd
event the george floyd killing
did
really didn't even didn't fit that
narrative but they made it fit that
narrative george floyd became this
innocent guy who was doing absolutely
nothing wrong and the officer became a
vicious white supremacist even though
there was really no evidence of that and
so it fit that narrative whereas what
happened in waukesha doesn't fit that
narrative because the guy there just
looking at his social media appears to
hate white people he espouses black
nationalist rhetoric hebrew israelite
rhetoric that's the kooky group that
believes that black people are real jews
and the jews are evil
and
according to the evidence that we have
he was swerving to hit people with his
car he wasn't trying to avoid them he
was actually gunning to hit people
so that narrative doesn't fit and so
he's not going to show up
and and a lot of politicians don't want
to
talk about it because the minute that
that you suggest that the left's
narrative on race or sex or whatever
isn't correct you're accused of being a
bigot or a racist or a phobe or whatever
stupid word they're going to call you
and so a lot of politicians even
republicans don't want to touch it they
say better just to sit back here and
let's just move on and let's just ignore
it one politician who's not just going
to ignore it
florida governor ron desantis
is that how it works the suvs they just
drive by themselves this just kind of
happened and they say oh this was a big
accident you never actually hear the
discussion about who committed this what
was the motivation
this guy was a career criminal let out
on didn't really have any bail basically
should not have even been on the street
had clear
anti-white animus
and this was an intentional act and it
seems like you know for corporate press
they're more apt to characterize a
parent who goes to a school board
meeting to protest bad policies as a
domestic terrorist than somebody who
intentionally rams an suv into a crowd
of innocent people and we'll see what
the actual motivation was
it very well may have been in response
to what happened with kyle rittenhouse
and you have to wonder if that's the
case
almost surely this guy's view of written
house was was colored by all these media
lies
this
press conference
was
basically perfect
it was written if you had
the most sophisticated
hollywood
slash
washington dc writer to hit every single
point you need to hit
he probably couldn't have done a better
job than what you just saw there in that
press conference
desantis is
getting the attack for what it was
he's demonstrating the courage to talk
about it to talk about crime first of
all
a lot of republicans now running away
from talking about crime they want to
talk about criminal justice reform and
letting the criminals out of prison
up to and including donald trump who did
that i love donald trump but but even he
made a big legislative effort to let
criminals out of prison desantis is
saying no we need to put more criminals
in prison should never have been out in
the first place
he's demonstrating the courage to talk
about the left's crazy racial narratives
he's saying look this is an anti-white
crime by all evidence that we've got
we always talk about anti-black
ness in in our culture but we never talk
about anti-white
discrimination and bigotry and he's
willing to talk about that so again
that's you're not supposed to touch that
that's not what the the establishment
wants you to talk about desantis is
willing to do it and then most important
of all beyond the crime and beyond the
left's kooky racial narratives
he's he's putting it all in the media
he's saying we'll find out what the
motivation was here but if the
motivation was
something to do with kenosha and kyle
rittenhouse then the media bears some
culpability here because the media
presented a narrative
to unhinged freaks like this guy in
waukesha
who
who probably believed the narrative that
kyle rittenhouse was a terrible white
supremacist and this was a racial attack
and it was just bs from the media
but
but freaks like the guy in in waukesha
aren't going to know that
and sometimes and so what what desantis
is saying is
this is
this crime
lives within a context of media
corruption
he opens up talking about the corporate
media closes talking about the corporate
media really smart the other thing that
desantis does here that's really clever
is injects himself into the story why is
the governor of florida
talking about a crime that took place in
wisconsin
why
who how does he do that i get why he
would talk about coronavirus and he's
been kind of the leading voice among
governors on coronavirus
but how is he going to inject himself
into this story in wisconsin well he's
holding a press conference about how
florida supports law enforcement
right so that's something that a
governor could do we support law
enforcement it was obviously an
opportunity it was bait for the media to
show up and then he can smack the media
down on the story in wisconsin because
it would seem clear to me that governor
desantis
is eyeing the presidency
it's very clever stuff he's he's
right on the issue
but he's also playing a pretty clever
game in terms of setting himself up to
run for president now if donald trump
runs for president again probably that's
dead on arrival
probably he clears the field but if not
he's positioning himself pretty well for
a guy who was relatively unknown
a couple of years ago glad you liked
that clip hold up
ring that bell
ring it
ring it then you'll get the
notifications and actually sometimes you
won't get the notifications because our
dear friends at big tech don't always
love to give our subscribers the
notifications that's why you got to go
over to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play subscribe to the michael
knowles show m-i-c-h-a-e-l-k-w-l-e-s
s-h-o-w subscribe leave a five-star
review we'll see
[Music]
you